if you've ever heard I left my wallet at
home here's the easiest way to avoid
that happening in the future rather than
asking someone for their credit card ask
them for their ID first so what happens
is they take out their wallet so you'll
be able to see the actual cards you take
their ID and then you say hey let me
trade you for whatever card you want to
use and you can flick it like this back
towards them and at that point they'll
trade you for the card for whatever
reason they then say I don't have the
card I want to use with me just say hey
well if you have your phone with you
open up your banking app real quick so
then click see statements and on the top
of the statement we'll have their
account number and you can actually do a
direct ACH to the account without even
needing the credit card problem solved